is the office that will be uh the duke
of sussex's new
uh place of work you can see the
shutters are uh pulled across
in these times of uh coronavirus of
course a lot of people working
remotely but the duke himself says he
intends to help create an impact
in people's lives which i guess explains
what a cheap impact officer
will do there aren't many of them in big
companies this uh
company better up uh connects personal
coaches to people a lot of big
international companies use them
actually they say to make people
feel more positive engaged and connected
with a focus on mental health and
actually one of the people who's been
using it for the last two months or so
is prince harry himself he in true
californian style says that the personal
coach he's been in touch with is
truly awesome he's received some sound
advice some fresh perspectives and
the head of the company said what they
wanted was uh someone who had a history
of advocacy of which of course the
prince had in the royal family
his military background is is key also a
very different background to anyone else
who works here
and they say he will be working this is
not just a celebrity being put on the
board
he will be an executive he will attend
meetings he will attend events once they
are
uh holding those uh those events again
so it's it's real work
they've not talked about the terms of
his employment any payment of course
he's a private citizen
so why should they but this is again
that next step we're seeing after deals
with netflix and spotify
of a step away from the royal family and
for the duke of sussex
it will be here when the the shutters
finally open